what are your motivations intentions and
desires tell the absolute
truth how do I know that you're not
moved by Vanity or
curiosity
I am moved by love I've never loved much
before so death hasn't been something to
be
avoided love comes first at the end of
the day what's more important than that
I know what it's like when it's there
and I know when it's like when it's
not so you've been in love before no no
I when I find
that that's all I
need
as a young girl I discovered I was an
infam
Maniac you have no idea what's
coming I ask to take my virginity with
that be a
problem because what's really happening
is that you're hiding something out
there
and it is going to send us back to the
Stone
Age you're not going
anywhere if you want me to come in and
watch if they don't want to watch the
show they can turn the
channel why don't you play something for
us as a way to introduce yourself to the
class
hey hey hey that's
mine
what a bunch of
a-holes
aahah ch